AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE PUBLIC
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STEP HOME ORDER WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO WE
WERE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THE MAP TO BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERSOF THE PUBLIC TEST
TO FIND WHETHER HERE IN THE
ROOM. OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE SITE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. BEFORE WE BEGIN I'M
GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES
TO GO THROUGH A FEW OPTIONS AND
PARTICLES. FOR WITNESS. IN
TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY ROOM
FORTY SEVEN OF THE- STATE
CAPITOL WE ARE IN THE MEETING.
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE ONCE
AGAIN A MINIMAL STAFF. THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN ONLY
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACE AND- THERE'S ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
HERE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL. OSU
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I ASK THAT
YOU NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
AFTER YOU'RE DONE SPEAKING. HE
CONNECTING ROOM AND RETURN YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE OBSERVERS
GO DISTANCING PARTICLES WHEN
LEAVING THE COPPER DURING
LIMITING. ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TEST FIRE FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME- BUILD WITNESSES TO
MAKE SURE. THE USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED. ON
THE COPPER GROUNDS FOR OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THOSE WITNESSES TO APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO THAT THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY. LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS IF WE
HAVE ANY CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS
AS WELL. WILL ALSO BE USING A
MARK MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THAT WITNESSES ALSO CAN
USED TO TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. ONCE AGAIN THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IT IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU'LL
FIND THIS PHONE NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL AND
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. YOUR FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
BEGINS THE BILL PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTION HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. YOUR FOR CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE INCLUDING MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE ON
THE MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. YOUR
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU
HAVING ANY QUESTIONS OR
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND MY STUFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THEY WERE ACCEPTING
RIBCHESTER MORNING. THROUGH THE
POSITION A REPORTER OF THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE ENCOURAGE
THOSE WHO HAVE ANY TECHNO
DIFFICULT IS TO USE THIS
OPTION. THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WILL ALSO BE
MINE FOR RESPECT OF THE HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. A FEW
MORE OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR
GET STARTED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL WAS ABSENT TODAY AND
THERE IS NO SUBSTITUTE FOR HIM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES IS
ALSO ABSENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA SUBSTITUTING FOR HER
TODAY WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA WINCING AFTER. WITHOUT SO
LET'S GET STARTED. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ENOUGH TO HEALTH SECRETARY
COLORADO STEP SHOULD FORM. YEAH
HERE ALL HEALTH. BONTA DURING.
BROUGH BURKE PRESIDENT BOB HERE
HOLD ON HERE FOR A LITTLE
PARKING. THANK YOU MEMBERS WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE HEARING ONE
BILL TODAY S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR RAWSON FROM FORT VISIT
YOUR BILL. ALSO CENTER DORADO I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT VIA THE
PHONE NUMBER HALF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CORRECT. OKAY THANK
YOU SO WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU. I'LL FONG
NEVER MADE. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WHEELER FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES OR THE VISION. THE
ACT AND TIMELY BARGAINING UNIT
INFORMATION TO WHICH THEY'RE
ALREADY ENTITLED TO BY LAW.
THAT WAY YOU CAN GO FAILED AS
LEGAL. MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
BARGAINING UNIT AS A WHOLE. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE LAW WAS
SIGNED THE GRANTED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS ACCESS
TO NEW HIRE CONTACT.
INFORMATION WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
OF THEIR HIRE DATE AS SPECIFIC
BARGAINING UNIT DATA AT LEAST
EVERY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS.
FOR EXAMPLE THIS INCLUDES
ACCESS TO WORKSITE AND OTHER
NECESSARY INFORMATION REGARDING
NURSES ON THE FRONT LINES AT
CRISIS HEALTH CARE CENTERS.
FIREFIGHTERS FIGHTING WILDFIRES
ACROSS THE STATE AND TEACHERS
CURRENTLY FACING THE
UNCERTAINTY OF WHERE WHEN AND
HOW SAFELY THEY WILL RETURN TO
WORK. DESPITE THIS SOME PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS STILL CHOOSE TO
IGNORE THEIR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR SEND.
INACCURATE OR OUT OF DATE
INFORMATION. SAYS THE MOST
RECENT REPORTING DEADLINE IN
MAY TWENTY FOUR EMPLOYERS
FAILED TO EVEN RESPOND TO THE
BARGAINING AGENT WITH NO
CONSEQUENCES. MANY EMPLOYERS
IGNORE OR DISREGARD THE LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS THEY HAVE. TO BOTH
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WILL
MAKE SURE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS DO A
BETTER JOB AT HEARING TO THE
LAW. IT ESTABLISHES THE
CREDIBILITY MARRIAGES WITH
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO CURE THE PROBLEM
AND RESPOND. THIS MEASURE
CREATES NO NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS. IT'S SIMPLY
INCENTIVIZES COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAW. THE CORONAVIRUS
CRISIS IS NOT GOING AWAY SOON
AND THEN PLOY IS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVE HAS
THE MRAL AND LEGAL DUTY TO
WATCH OUT FOR THE WELFARE OF
THESE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO IN
TURN. WATCH OUT FOR THE
PUBLIC'S WELLBEING. THIS CRISIS
HAS SHOWN THAT TODAY IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE ENTIRE BARGAINING UNIT. AND
ENSURE WORKPLACE SAFETY. FOR
THESE REASONS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BRING ELEVEN- SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BEFORE YOU.
URGENT I VOTE. AND I WILL HAVE
OUR WITNESSES SPEAK NOW THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER SO NOW. THANK YOU SIR SO
NOW IT'S GOING TO REMAIN
WITNESSES WE'LL START WITH SIR
FLOCKS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND THEN AFTER
WE HEAR FROM SUNDA. BORROWED
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
THAT PLAYED SOCIAL ACTION
CEREMONY THERE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR. WONDERFUL
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE
FLOCKS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE'RE PROUD
SPONSOR AS SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WE WERE ALO ONE OF THE
PROPONENTS OF THE CURRENT LAW
THAT GIVES ACCESS TO NEW HIRE
DATA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND THAT
WAS BECAUSE IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR UNIONS TO BE ABLE
TO FIND WORKERS SO THAT WE CAN
REPRESENT THEM. AS YOU KNOW
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OR WORKPLACES
IN EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE
FROM SMALL SCHOOLS TO MASSIVE
HOSPITALS AND FAR FLUNG OFFICES.
AND REALLY THIS PANDEMIC HAS
MADE IT EVEN MORE CRITICAL TO
BE ABLE TO REACH WORKERS.
WORKERS HAVE QUESTIONS ON
ACCESS TO BP PAID SICK DAYS IF
THEY HAVE TO QUARANTINE THE
RIGHT TO REFUSE UNSAFE WORK AND
A MYRIAD OF OTHER URGENT
QUESTIONS AND ISSUES. SO RIGHT
NOW AS AS UNIONS WE DON'T JUST
HAVE A LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
REPRESENT WORKERS WE HAVE A
MORAL OBLIGATION TO SUPPORT AND
REPRESENT WORKERS DURING WHAT
IS THE IS A REALLY SCARY TIME
JUST TO COME TO WORK. DISTURB
WALK INTO THE HEARING ROOM THAT
YOU ALL ARE IN RIGHT NOW. AND
UNFORTUNATELY SOME EMPLOYERS
HAVE FAILED TO COMPLY WITH THE
CURRENT LAW. AND THERE'S LITTLE
RECOURSE FOR UNIONS. SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE CREATES A REAL
DETERRENT BY ALLOWING UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES AND
ESTABLISHING EIGHT APRIL
PENALTY. BUT IT'S ALSO A
BALANCE BECAUSE IT GIVES
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
COMPLY A RIGHT CLICK HERE AND A
VERY GENEROUS RIGHT TO CARE. WE
THINK THIS IS A REASONABLE BELT
TO MAKE SURE UNIONS CAN. DO THE
JOB THAT THEY THEY NEED TO DO
TO FIND WORKERS THAT THEY
REPRESENT AGAINST ACROSS THE
STATE WITHOUT CREATING AN UNDUE
BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
A SANDRA ARE YOU THERE FROM THE
SCHOOL. CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. YES I'M
HERE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. IN
GOVERNMENT OKAY YES WE'RE GOING
HERE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
VANDERBUR ERROL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE CO SPONSORS
OF THE CELL THE GOAL OF AT
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE IS
COMPLIANCE IDEALLY WE'D NEVER
HAVE TO USE STAFF TIME AND
RESOURCES TO GO TO THE PERFECT
EMPLOYERS TO FOLLOW THE LAW.
AND MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS CSEA
REPRESENTS ARE IN COMPLIANCE SO
OR INSTANCE OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY REPRESENT. THE
MAJORITY HAVE THE FULL
BARGAINING UNIT LISTS DUE IN
MAY AND TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY DID
NOT SUBMIT THE LISTS AND ARE
THEREFORE OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
AND THIS MOVE ACTUALLY
IMPORTANT DURING THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS INCLUDING THOSE IN FOOD
SERVICE. I HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ADEQUATE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT VERNE TROYER'S. AND
OTHER UNIONS THE NCCA WE ARE
TRACKING BOTH EMPLOYEES DOWN
AND ACTUALLY PROVIDING THE FROM
PP TO THEM THROUGH THE UNION.
BUT WE NEED THE INFORMATION
REQUIRED BY AB ONE ONE NINE TWO
GERMAN WHICH OF OUR MEMBERS
STILL NEED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT TO FAITHFULLY SERVE
THE PUBLIC. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SANDRA THE NEXT WILL
GO TO OTHERS ON THE PHONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
OPERATOR LET'S GO THROUGH THE
Q. OFFER OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY.
CALLERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE CALL. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. IN
ONE MOMENT WITH THE GERMAN.
LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I
WAS ACTUALLY CALLING IN
OPPOSITION SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND- THAT BE HAPPY TO HOLD
UNTIL THAT TIME. BUT THE TERM
DID YOU WANT TO GO TO BOTH
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
NOTICE THE GO TO SUPPORT ONLY.
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU TERM.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. NUMBER
SIXTEEN LESLIE TO RE QUEUE UP
ONE MOMENT. NUMBER NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER AND MEMBERS THAT THE
SEPTEMBER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EDUCATORS THE MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION THE MACHINISTS
AND I. S. T. E. LOCALS TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE ALL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TAYLOR
DOCKRAY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND UNION
NURSES- MANY OF WHOM ARE PUBLIC
SECTOR WOULD GREATLY BENEFIT
FROM THE BILL ARE WE ARE AT
YOUR SUPPORT ABOUT THE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GOOD CARE OF ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND THE
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BACK CRIME AND CAL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA THAT A
COOPERATIVE OPERATING ENGINEERS
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
IT'S NOT SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
WHAT OUR LAST PERSON IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR THE
NEXT WILL GO TO A WEB VIDEO AND
REMOTE VIDEO STATIONS DO WE
HAVE BEEN ANY WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TESTIMONY SO. IF
SO PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND IF ANY
POSITION ON THE ON THE BILL.
BOSER REGISTER WITH THAT
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THE OPERATOR DO WE STILL
HAVE SOME ROOM FOR PROPOSITION
WE JUST DO IT AS WELL. CORRECT
YES THAT WE DO HAE SOMEONE
FROM. I CAN QUEUE UP FOR
SOMEONE I'M OPPOSITION. OKAY GO
AHEAD. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
THE GERMAN. MY NUMBER SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YEAH. THANK YOU
THAT CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEALING
GIVEN TIME WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
CALLING OPPOSITION THAT A LEVIN
SEVENTY THREE- IMMINENT YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR MY COLLEAGUE OF MR
SPELLS ARE SO I DON'T. GOING TO
THE SAME HE WILL BUT- I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS BILL IS
ONE OF SEVERAL ATTEMPTS TO
ALTER THE BROKERED AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE UNIONS
SURROUNDING PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATIONS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS. REGARDING THE JANUS
DECISION FROM ONLY THREE YEARS
AGO. I'LL TAKE TO ADD FINANCIAL
PENALTIES WHERE THERE COULD
QUITE PURPOSELY BEEN DONE- THIS
BILL WOULD BE HARMFUL TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES SERVING THE PUBLIC AT
AT THE BEST OF TIMES. BUT TO
ADD FINANCIAL PENALTIES TO
STRUGGLING PUBLIC AGENCIES
DURING A PANDEMIC FOR OFFICE
WORK MISTAKES WHILE ALSO
ENCOURAGING EMPLOYEES NOT TO
WORK IN THEIR OFFICES. JUST
DOESN'T MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF
SENSE- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS TO PAY FINES
AND ATTORNEY'S FEES. NOT SO
WEALTHY PRIVATE CORPORATION-
BOTTOM LINE REDUCE PUBLIC
DOLLARS RESULT IN REDUCED
PUBLIC SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
POSITION I ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
ON SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WE HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE. THE TERM IN LINE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- CHICKEN
SHELTER HERE ON BEHALF OF FOR
THEM THAT PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT- ALL THE OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF A
DEAL AND ADDED AT A FEW THINGS-
THAT I SAID THIS IN THE FIRST
HEARING UPDATE AGAIN WE
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT
PUBLISHED THESE SHOULD BE
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW- WE
NEGOTIATED A LOT WITH FOLKS AND
WE BELIEVE THE OTHER FOLKS TO
COMPLY. LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
AND ALL- KNOWLEDGE THAT
OCCURRED TWO DIFFERENT NUMBERS
AFTER WHICH POINT WHEN THAT'S
BUT LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
WHAT WAS PROVIDED BY THE
AUTHOR. WHAT MEDICATION THAT
TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE MAYES FILING DEADLINE
HADN'T I HADN'T REPLIED WE
WOULD POINT OUT OF MY QUICK
GOOGLING AT OF THAT THERE'S A
THOUSAND THIRTY SEVEN DISTRICT.
OF THAT WOULD BE. CAN'T
COMPLAIN GET. THAT NINETY SEVEN
POINT 7% AND I GOT MORE
STRUGGLING HOW THAT INDICATES
THAT A SEVERE PROBLEM BUT AGAIN
I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT
THE WHAT THE OTHER WITH THAT
SAID- ABOUT THERE BEING A
HIGHER NUMBER. I GOT THAT WOULD
POINT OUT. MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY
WITH THE STRUGGLE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE. ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
SUBJECTS I DON'T KNOW THAT
USING THAT- IN TERMS OF
PAPERWORK FILING DEADLINE IS
THE IT'S A GOOD. MECHANISM FOR
DETERMINING HOW PEOPLE ARE ARE
PERFORMING UNDER THE LAW- RIGHT
NOW IT'S STILL AN INDICATED
STATE LOCAL REVENUES ARE VERY
LIMITED RIGHT- THE BOTH THE
STATE AND CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE ARE WAITING. FOR FEDERAL
STIMULUS HOPING TO BACK FILL
COFFERS- SERVICES AE ARE
BOOKED BY HAVING INCREASED
DEMAND AND WE'RE HAVING A
CHALLENGE FUNDING THEM- SO WE
JUST DON'T KNOW THE RIGHT NOW.
BEEN PROVIDED THAT DOESN'T SEEM
TO INDICATE A SEVERE PROBLEM-
IT'S TIME THAT WE SHOULD BE
DIVERTING RESOURCES AWAY. FROM
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
MUCH NEEDED SERVICES THAT WITH
THAT- I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR YOUR NOTEBOOK. TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE HAVEN'T ELSE.
THE CHAIRMAN LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR CARAVACA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BURBANK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU OPERATOR
AND BODY ELSE. CAROLINA TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU JEFF DEAL HERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO
WERE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBER STATE
FORGET ABOUT THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE YOU KNOW A LINER COMMENT
BUT THAT DIDN'T TAKE IT AND
THEN SHOP THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WERE NEXT.
NUMBER SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE BEVERAGE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ANYONE
ACCESS. THE GERMAN THAT WAS OUR
LAST PERSON. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LIVE VIDEO AND
REMOTE VIDEO STATIONS DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. IF SO
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY POSITION ON
THE BILL IN BRIEF COMMENTS.
I'VE BEEN FORM ARE SERGEANTS
THAT THERE WAS NOBODY IN ANY OF
THE ROOMS. US WITHOUT SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM WITH THIS PRESIDENT
AND NOW WE WERE THE WITNESSES
HERE THEY'RE WITH US IN THE
HEARING ROOM. DO WE HAVE
WITNESS IS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FOR TO THE MICROPHONE AND
WITHOUT TOUCHING IT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND IF ANY POSITION ON THE BILL
AND BRIEF COMMENTS. SEE NON IN
THE HEARING ROOM. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS- LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SOME MEMBER COOPER
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I DON'T
THINK THE CENTER FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD- I DO HAVE A B.
FIFTY TWO THERE WAS A- AUTHOR
DURING- THE JANUS DECISION AND
IT IT IT IT SAID HEY- SO THE
MOTION A NUMBER OF THINGS IT
WAS A BIG ISSUE WAS. BROWN'S
FOR SECOND COUNTY BACK IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. IT'S A
BRAND NEW EMPLOYEE SAT DOWN THE
UNION WAS IN TOUCH WITH THE
DIDN'T DIDN'T DO FULL TALK
ABOUT FOUR OH ONE K. INSURANCE
ADJUSTER REALLY A MYRIAD OF
THINGS IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT THE
UNIONS FOR A FOR A BRAND NEW
EMPLOYEE AND IN OTHER
SUBSEQUENT JOBS THAT HASN'T
BEEN DONE- NEW PLACE FOR THE
CAPITAL AREN'T SAT DOWN AND
TOLD THIS. THE NEXT IMPORTANT
FOR NUMBER OF REASONS IT IS
JUST GOOD POLICY GOOD PRACTICE
TO TELL YOU EMPLOYEES
ESPECIALLY IF YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT A FOUR OH ONE K.
IS AN INVALID SHARON'S YOU KNOW
LIFE INSURANCE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
HAPPEN. THAT ALSO WITH
EMPLOYEES D. WHAT HEY HERE'S
WHAT WE CAN DO FOR YOU IS YOUR
UNION AND CAN'T BEFORE YOU SO
TO ME IT WORKS GOOD AND IT ALSO
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TIME TO
CORRECT MISTAKES. THE BILL IS
APPLY SO THERE IS TIME IS JUST.
TO ME THAT'S A BETTER WORK
ENVIRONMENT. AND ESPECIALLY THE
YOUNG. KIDS COMMUNITIES DAYS.
MAYBE THEIR PARENTS DIDN'T MEAN
THOMAS HEY MAKE SURE YOU INVEST
IN YOUR FOUR OH ONE K. AND DO
THIS TYPE OF THING SO TO ME. IT
MAKES A BETTER FOR EMPLOYEES.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO- SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR- I
PREACH BRINGS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. C. NONE SENATE RATHER
LIKE CLOSE YES- I APPRECIATE
THE TIME THAT YOU'VE GIVEN ME
UP YOU LOOK THIS ISN'T NOT THIS
ISN'T A BILL AIMED AT. LOOKING
TO PENALIZE AND MAKE MONEY THIS
IS ABOUT ENFORCING THE LAW
THAT'S ON THE BOOKS THAT'S BEEN
PASSED. AND ALL OF THOSE- YOU
KNOW SOMEBODY REFERRED TO IT AS
AS A MISTAKE IF IT'S A MISTAKE
YOU CAN HEAR IT. AND THERE IS
NOT NOPE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT
WE ALL THE MISTAKES BUT THIS IS
ABOUT THOSE WHO HAVE REPEATEDLY
REFUSED IGNORED AND NOT
PROVIDED CORRECT INFORMATION
AND IT'S INFORMATION THEY HAVE
IN THEIR HANDS SO WE'RE NOT
ASKING THEM TO DO SOMETHING
THEY WOULDN'T OTHERWISE HAVE.
NAMES THAT OF THE EMPLOYEES
WHERE THEY WORK- SO THERE IS A
GREATER URGENCY NOW AND ALL OF
THOSE PUBLIC SERVANTS THAT DO A
SERVICE FOR US IN A- IN
CALIFORNIA. REALLY DESERVE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR BARGAINING
UNIT REPRESENTATIVE SO FOR ALL
THOSE AND MANY MORE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
DRAWS ARE HERE THE CONCERNS OF
THE ALL OF THE PONENS GIVEN THE
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT IT
MAKES SENSE TO ME AT THIS TIME
THAT FROM PORES ARE COMPLYING
WITH THE LAW REGARDLESS OF THE
ISSUE WE NEED TO ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM TO. DISCOURAGE NON
COMPLIANCE IN THE FUTURE. THIS
BILL DOES THAT I THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL AND I'M ALSO
RECOMMENDING AYE VOTE AND WITH
THAT SAID I WANT TO GET A
MOTION AND SECOND. SECOND A
MOTION BY. O'DONNELL SECOND
BARKER'S COOPER HAS MORE
CERTAIN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IN A RE REFER TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL. BONTA
BONTA AYE COOLEY COOPER ALL
RIGHT COOPER HI FONG. BONDO
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I. THIS
THE MOTION PASSES FOR ONE THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THREE SHADED IN WITH
THAT THANK YOU MEMBERS OF STAFF
FROM THE PUBLIC TODAY- WITHOUT
SEEING NO FURTHER BUSINESS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU.
IF UP.